TV
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Piers Morgan uncensored with
Kate McCann and Harry Cole British
forces begin the perilous evacuation of
stricken Nationals from Sudan amid a
blaze of criticism that they took far
too long defense secretary Ben Wallace
joins us live
President Biden confirms who runs the
White House again the oldest president
in history would be 86 by the end of his
second term so how old is too old for
the lead of the Free World Stanley
Johnson makes the case for political
antiques
plus labor talks tough on boyish banter
with a pledge to teach women respect
respect for women is this an overdue
Reckoning for classroom misogyny or an
attack on masculinity we will debate
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored good
evening from London and welcome to Piers
Morgan uncensored eagle-eyed viewers
would have spotted that neither of us is
Piers Morgan sadly he was up all night
with a sickness bug
these overnight pictures of Harry and
Megan smooching at a basketball game are
we're told entirely a coincidence we
wish peers a speedy recovery and in his
honor we'll have a packed hour of box
office material
well shortly we will be bringing you an
interview with the defense secretary Ben
Wallace and of course Harry that is
about the situation that's unfolding in
Sudan at the minute and I think one of
the biggest questions for the government
that really we are going to be putting
to Ben Wallace and if he's watching Ben
Wallace then you're going to get a hint
about our interview that's coming up
shortly is the fact that the government
had a test case here they they had the
trial of Afghanistan they tried to get
people out it was a complete mess and
the situation now they're coming in for
a huge amount of criticism in Sudan yeah
it's not like they haven't been talking
about us for a couple of weeks now
there's been a number of emergency
meetings the other countries seem to
have managed to get their citizens and
their diplomats out we seem to only
manage to get our diplomats so mounting
questions for what's going on at the
heart of government and more questions
really for the foreign office as well
yeah and I think one of the questions
really for the government is and we were
talking about this earlier when we were
planning what to ask Ben Wallace today
is the fact that Giles lever was not in
Sudan now he's the British Ambassador he
was in London when all of this was
unfolding and there are some serious
questions about whether actually the the
situation with Dominic Brad that the
Prime Minister was having to deal with
at the time also caused a bit of a
distraction yeah did the government have
the eye on the ball were they fighting
you know on with a full team clearly the
the
excruciatingly embarrassing scenario for
the ambassador to be at his home in
wooden rather than with his team on the
ground but also there's questions of why
they pulled the diplomats out first
rather than have left a lot of them
there to try and extract much assistants
and there's a huge number of them four
thousand there's a lot of dual citizens
there yeah well look we're gonna we're
gonna bring you that interview with Ben
Wallace the defense secretary as soon as
he arrives he's hot footing it to a
camera as we speak but for the moment
let's just have a quick chat about U.S
President Joe Biden because he's
announced his intention to run for a
second term in the white house today now
in a campaign video released this
morning Biden pledges to finish the job
and continue his fight against what he
calls Republican extremism but will the
job finish him already the oldest
president in history Biden would be 86
by the end of a second term his blunders
are already subjected daily scrutiny
well 10 12 15. up stepping on them
that's black anyway
[Music]
happy birthday to you happy birthday
dear Valley
[Music]
president asked me to be in charge of
managing that peace than president Trump
excuse me Freudian slip that was the
last president
because anyway that was President Obama
[Applause]
joining us now is the environmentalist
and former prime minister Boris
Johnson's father Stanley Johnson welcome
Stanley I thought you're going to say
it's a tongue twister
Sally let's start with with Joe Biden's
age he's a bit he's a bit over the hill
isn't he I don't agree with that at all
I mean it's not like I said you know
he's got the whole world in front of him
if I think about it
he was 87 when he when he gave up and
Biden's not going to be 87 even if he
serves the whole time but you saw that
video there he said you know he gets
into these blunders he's tripping
upstairs he's falling off bikes surely
There's real concerns about the man with
his finger on the nuclear button We All
Fall Off bikes I have been falling off
bikes all my life and I think actually
you think what he's actually done in
terms of the experience which he brings
to this job it's worth going in in the
case where are the candidates where
where are the other people stepping
forward oh I was going to ask you that
because it's a pretty serious question
here isn't there about the fact that you
know okay you say that it age isn't a
problem some people would disagree with
you and they might think that it's not a
particularly good luck for the president
of the United States to be for example
forgetting the name of the British prime
minister which one there has been a few
yeah that's fair enough but it was a
pronunciation issue not forgetting the
name entirely but I think the question
really is for the party why have they
not been able to find a better candidate
it is a very good question now maybe you
know Kamal Harris didn't
quite get there and maybe she maybe she
will get there next time around I don't
think you're going to do another time
he's allowed to do another time that's
for sure yeah it's a it's a mystery to
me why there have not been another good
Democratic candidate if they had an age
limit for example they'd be forced to
look elsewhere wouldn't they I mean that
would that would be a cut-off Point yes
I don't know there's a society where
there are age limits for well their age
limits for driving you have to be a
certain age to drive the age of is for
being a president well again I go back
to it if I think of as it were the
alternatives to Mr Biden in terms of him
not winning the election I say to myself
look stick with what you know here
because I would say and of course I'm
speaking his environment he's very kind
of Harry and his environment I look at
what Mr Biden has done quite recently on
the environment and it's pretty good
news the so-called strangely named
inflation reduction Act is actually also
with an environmental policy it's good
it's good stuff so I am I am you know
bashing for bride for Biden here I don't
think these gas are particularly
important some retirement today and said
Pierce Morgan is is not well because
he's being poisoned by Sushi I said well
who's Susie you know people do make some
mistakes obviously but the problem is I
think what voters will wonder is you
know he is the leader of the Free World
should his age and should his mental
status be a concern to people let's go
back let's go back let's have a little
bit of historical perspective here
Gladstone well over 80 during his last
Administration I don't know I I've
already mentioned Ronald Reagan Ronald
Reagan was getting up getting up to 80.
I think he might even have been 80 by
the time he by the time he stepped on
they're just saying that Reagan wasn't a
good stand good bed Stanley might have
got here there's a question I've been
meaning to ask you next time I see you
am I going to be calling you sir Stanley
Johnson no I absolutely absolutely no
idea I know no idea what you're talking
about happily I've been reportedly on
your son's resignation on his list would
you accept the Knighthood I have no idea
anything of that nature and in any case
even if I did have an idea as I
understand it etiquette is such never
ever
[Laughter]
would you accept it though back to Biden
abiding my I'm biting Biden my time on
this one
I don't think that was the denial I
think that was I think he left the door
open well they may well find out this
week um but you know speaking of Boris
Johnson they've been I mean you read the
newspapers there's been some some
interesting Revelations about his
response to the brexit vote today
Anthony Selden extracts of course uh
from his reporting suggesting that Boris
said crikey I didn't expect that we
don't have a plan
well now you catch me here because I was
a remainder am I allowed to admit here
in the holy of holies the lives of men
are not really rain I fought to you know
to keep us in we set up an organization
called environmentalists for Europe we
fought rather hard and I was determined
that we didn't want to throw out the
baby with the bath water as far as the
environmental policies and actually I've
still been doing that you see because I
was really worried by this something
called retained European environmental
legislation which you know this is
response plan took scrap all the
environmental laws so
coming back to the to the substance
coming back to suddenly your question
yes of course it was a it was a strange
but do you think he said it
what year was it reported to have said
by um by Mr Sultan you're probably
surrounded cheers
something like crikey or something
Frankie did we did we said we don't have
a plan was that right well not everybody
who wins has a plan you know sometimes
the first step is to win you didn't
necessarily have to have a fully fledged
plan but that said yeah that said I
think he had to live through the
consequences as we all have as we'll
have briefly before we let you go I just
want to get your response to something
because it's the first time that you've
been interviewed on on television since
this happened and it's it's Fiona Bruce
Biden Biden Fiona Bruce on question time
let's just have a quick look to remind
ourselves of what happened
it was a wife beater Stanley Johnson on
record
um okay let me just let me just
interview I'm not I'm not disputing what
we're saying but just so everyone knows
what this is referring to so Sally
Johnson's uh wife spoke to a journalist
tombar and she said that Stanley Johnson
had broken her nose and she'd end up in
hospital as a result Stanley Johnson has
not commented publicly on that friends
of his have said it did happen it was a
one-off yes but it did happen well look
you just said took me on the break there
I am going to comment publicly first
your response to what was said you know
something that is such total garbage I
mean total garbage as far as I'm
concerned you know if I have a chance
for a comment public on Jones is total
garbage I have my Consciousness 100
clear and honestly I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna name himself I hope that I have
never have to meet the people involved
but I do not believe I do not believe
that anybody who knows me anybody who
knows the 40 years I have passed as a
real friend with my former wife since we
got
divorced will know that he is totally so
was what happened to Fiona Bruce unfair
because she lost her position with the
charity
Bruce I think did as she
did the right thing now had she been
fully fully briefed have she been fully
briefed she would have read the
statement yeah which was made by my
sister which said look actually poor
Stanley jolson's wife Stanley Johnson's
wife Charlotte suffered from obsessional
compulsive disorder and yes the only
time that happened was as a result of a
of a domestic I mean it was absurd
absurd and I have felt very strongly
about it well thank you so much for the
response Sandy Johnson thank you for
joining us next tonight we will speak to
the defense secretary Ben Wallace who is
raring to go just after the break
[Music]
thank you
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no out with the people's Channel nobody
use uh every little helps for God's sake
is nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at 7
pm join me just do it well that one too
[Music]
thank you foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Felts is
on talk TV every night of the week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
welcome back the first UK evacuation
flight from Sudan has now landed in
Cyprus with two more planned overnight
while we're joined by the defense
secretary Ben Wallace now to talk
through all of this Ben thank you so
much for joining us this evening let's
start with what's happening in Sudan
we've been talking about it a little
earlier on in the program why wasn't the
government faster in responding to this
situation
well I think we went in at exact the
same time as the French we were the
first in so uh you know you could argue
why why didn't the International
Community see this coming and I think
that you know that that is that is those
are questions uh to be answered I think
in in any inquiries but I think
fundamentally when it did deteriorate
the British the French and the United
States all went in on the same night it
was important uh to make sure we were
coordinated but it was also important
that we've got permission of the
Sudanese Armed Forces they are the
government of Sudan and they were not
only fighting their their side of the
conflict but also they control the
airspace and indeed the airfields we
needed so so we had to do some
negotiations we all had to coordinate
and get permissions and then when we did
we went in and the difference between
the French and the British was a matter
of hours in fact the British early parts
of the British forces went in with the
United States first
well I mean I think there is some
criticism though of the fact that you
know there are lots of British Nationals
and their dependents who are saying
we've not heard anything we don't know
where to go we're not sure whether the
government knows that we're here I mean
it's taken eight emergency meetings to
get to this point the first flight of
course has left
I mean can you really say that you learn
any lessons from what happened in
Afghanistan
yeah I mean first of all this is not
Afghanistan so in Afghanistan the
Taliban were in control and gave us a
20-day window so there was some
certainty that we would be able to fly
in and out secondly in Afghanistan we
and the Americans had had military
troops on the ground for 20 years so
there was a proper footprint and a large
Embassy there's many more people to get
out thirdly in Afghanistan we expanded
not just British passport holders if you
remember the Arab scheme which is some
nearly 12 000 people those are people
who over the 20 years had helped us it's
very different and also the chaos and
the things that we saw at the
humanitarian challenges around the
Airfield are not here yeah you know what
was what was going on in Sudan what was
going on Sudan okay was that you know
first of all the International Community
because of the fighting and the
Diplomatic quarter was sandwiched
between the two headquarters of the two
factions because of the fighting you
know knowing hour by hour was going on
was very difficult and you reference
people not having heard from the foreign
office that isn't because the foreign
office isn't trying to communicate with
them it is because the internet cover
the television the television telephone
cover is very very minimal at some
stages two percent and that presents I
suppose that's my point really because
the foreign office is supposed to be
able to see these things coming it's
supposed to have the planning and the
resources to know that they have what
they need on the ground to get people
out you are of course in charge of what
happens when people are airlifted out of
a country and and what you seem to be
saying is that that is going well so
actually is that the foreign office
letting the side down again here
no look I mean look the whole entire
Community
if you think realized what was going on
uh but it descended pretty quickly into
a fight you know Sudan had settled into
some form of stability where the the two
factions were supposed to merge together
to form the main Army uh suddenly I mean
literally in a space of a few days or
hours that broke down and the two
leaders of the Sudanese armed forces and
indeed the rsf the the the former sort
of uh uh janjaweed militia some people
might remember from the past uh started
fighting and they started fighting
around the area of the Diplomatic sector
that that meant a matter of hours and a
country like Sudan it's very difficult
poor infrastructure very poor country uh
that that presented some real problems
and look you know we made a decision
early on that the people directly
Secretary of State you're saying there's
no criticism at all for for the foreign
office absolutely none you're perfectly
happy with how it went
look we are all learning we're all
working together uh you know I don't
criticize the foreign office people
often expect the front office have a
sort of magic wand you know uh you know
this was a very difficult and dangerous
environment and it was absolutely right
that the first advice was hunker down
that's important you didn't want people
moving around in the middle of a
conflict and and one of the reasons
we've changed advice is twofold one is
after a few days the food and water
problem uh becomes a greater risk to
those people and therefore they may be
better off actually trying to move to
extract themselves and the second thing
uh Harry is that there's been a 72 hour
ceasefire and thirdly we've got to know
more about what's going on the ground
because of our experience since the
weekend and I think that that allows us
to have a window in Khartoum and 99 of
the people registered with the foreign
office are all in Khartoum at the moment
but I do expect that to change but in
the meantime I've put in place plans in
Port Sudan which is 500 miles away but
nevertheless one of the major towns in
Sudan I've put some Royal Marines in
there and working with the Sudanese
Armed Forces to make sure there is a
backup should that Airfield and and your
listeners should should remember and
viewers that the Airfield is a military
Airfield from which the the conflict is
being run from so we're only guests
there and we have to be slightly careful
about how many people we put in and how
much we get in the way of the Sudanese
of course Secretary of State and um you
speak on behalf there of the
International Community talk about
working with allies are you um you're
pitching for the top job at NATO again
no no I'm pitching on helping as many of
our friends and allies as possible we've
taken out we took out French we took out
Norwegians we took out Danish and we'll
take out on these planes if there are
seat spare or indeed you know as the
Germans have found out not not all their
Nationals turn up at the same time so we
will take out all our friends and allies
across the world so you're not
interested then in being the next
Secretary General of NATO I hear you're
in the running
I I'm always interested in a variety of
interesting jobs Harry at the moment the
job I have is the defense secretary but
you're not saying never
right when I left school as a ski
instructor Harry I'm always interested
in getting back to do that job that's
another now there that's quite a grin I
think Ben Wallace um look it's where she
say next six months in office today you
didn't Back Him originally for the job
as he convinced you now that he is the
right man
yeah he he's doing an excellent job and
I I witnessed firsthand over the last a
few days his chairing of Cobra has been
very good it's been efficient and he's
taken the decisions you know sending men
and women In Harm's Way is not an easy
job for people to do he's done it really
really well he's LED from the front he's
whenever I've needed assistance to speak
to another leader so we could get more
troops in or more aircraft he's done it
he's delivered and I think he's he's
providing that stability that the
country currently needs well I mean as
you say is providing that stability but
he just lost his Deputy Prime Minister
not even a week ago
yeah
the Prime Minister took a decision based
on the report he read it was a I think
it wasn't an easy decision because I
don't think it was overwhelming uh one
way or the other but you know we have to
make sure we stand uh for some of the
you know issues people civil servants
were were feeling certainly in the
evidence they gave that this was a
behavior that that wasn't appropriate I
think it's it's a difficult call but I
think he wanted to uphold the higher
standards but but also on the other side
you know Dominic Rabb I worked with uh
when he was foreign secretary uh finally
if I recognize the the issue about
Gibraltar I think in that uh some of
those uh claims he made were correct and
I think it's it's very tough sometimes
when you're working under pressure as a
leader of a department to make sure you
get you get the outcomes you need but
you know the Prime Minister read the
report I haven't read the report myself
he read it he took a decision I think it
was a tough decision but you know the
price of leadership is sometimes tough
it sounds like you think that she's not
could have fought a little bit harder
for his Deputy Prime Minister there in
that case
no I think Rishi as I've seen him in his
six months he absolutely uh he reads the
briefs he's given he reads the reports
he makes an analytical view of what what
he thinks he's going to do he talks to
the leaders of the department so if it's
a defense matter he will talk to me and
then he makes his decision and I think
he he made a decision in that case by
all accounts I think it was a difficult
decision uh because it wasn't
necessarily overwhelming but it was a
decision but I think he heard in the
right place and he took a he took that
tough call I mean Ben Wallace appears
Morgan very sadly isn't here tonight and
we are doing our best to uh to keep his
seat warm well I'm not being shouted out
usually
there's still there's plenty of time but
look there is a question that Piers
Morgan wanted to ask you tonight let's
just have a quick listen to him talking
about this topic
I hope prime minister did the right
thing this man is a hero who helped us
take on the Taliban his family are in
Afghanistan we have a moral compulsion
as a country to save this man and to
take care of him and to take care of his
family
is a plea there from Piers Morgan to the
Prime Minister fair enough but I'm
putting the question to you tonight
because Pierce is saying that the Prime
Minister should step in and not Deport
this Afghan pilot who has entered the UK
of course you know as the government
would say illegally but has done a huge
amount for this country in the past
well first of all when I heard about
that I asked and I asked my department
to look if he'dra applied under the Arab
scheme which was the scheme for those
people in Afghanistan who had helped
support or work directly with the United
Kingdom mainly security forces and the
foreign office over those 20 years and
it transpired he hadn't applied and he
has now applied for the arap scheme and
I think he did that at the beginning of
April when it was first presented to me
we will work through his application
I've asked my officials to keep an eye
on that and we'll then see what comes
the outcome and and we'll you know we'll
make sure to see if it meets the the
criteria of the Arab scheme and I think
you know the Arab scheme has some
differences that people might have
forgotten now which was you know if
you're in the mainstream Afghan Army for
example when you're a soldier in the
Army but you weren't working with the
British or the American Royals you
weren't eligible for that scheme because
you were you know we didn't want the
Army at the time just to all leave and
we wanted obviously them to to stay and
support their government so the Taliban
weren't Victorious if you work directly
for us or or in support of us over those
20 years then you were eligible and and
your you know viewers and listeners will
know that that's been in the you know
thousands of people we've brought over
already we'll we will continue to do so
we're not closing that scheme so we'll
look through his application and then
obviously I'm very happy to make it
clear what the result is on that it
sounds like an element of Hope there in
that difficult story Ben Wallace defense
secretary thank you so much for giving
us your time this evening
thank you Kate thank you
well next tonight should boys we talk to
respect girls at school to stop misogyny
and violence that's coming up next
[Music]
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel no we're
gonna use every little helps for God's
sake is nothing original anymore it's
finger licking Goods I'm loving it look
let's be honest we don't have any fancy
speech writers here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7 pm join me just do it what
that one too
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
this is talk TV
Prime Minister President Trump Mr
President first lady Stormy Daniels
Jordan Peterson welcome to all these
people protesting just don't get it many
of them don't it's not slightly
patronizing
[Music]
so when you're going through the
treatments you have some tears God I'm
such a softy I think my sister is her
husband's property do you regret saying
it like that a woman is given to the man
in marriage Andrew You're simply wrong
and it's something that really hurt me
because they doubt of my word
start the marginalize we're supposed to
have a voice I've been a terrible liar
you're being a Karen pass Morgan
Florida Governor sat down with Pierce
Morgan which is your favorite nickname
that Trump's giving us Rhonda
sanctimonious or meatball Rock
oh
[Music]
welcome back and wow what a load of
guests there a year since we've been on
air and quite a year it's been a labor
is pledging a Crackdown on Ladish banter
today in classrooms and says that boys
should be taught respect for women as
part of the national curriculum our
schools are reportedly battling
increases in misogyny and abusive
Behavior towards girls blamed by some on
the popularity of influences like Andrew
Tate but what's fuel of that popularity
in the first place and is it really the
roles of schools to fix it joining us
now is talk to you talk TV contributor
Esther kraku and broadcaster Jenny
cleeman so Esther to you first what what
is wrong with teaching boys respect in
schools I mean is chivalry dead
some might say feminism killed it what
is the responsibility of parents I don't
see why you know of all the with all the
pressure that teachers are under they
now have the added responsibility of
teaching young boys how to behave
properly but I also have an issue with
how this this sort of
discussion is Being Framed they're
they're equating bad behavior towards
women or whatever are solely being men's
fault what about teaching women respect
for boys I mean we talk about the
popularity of you know people like
Andrew Tate but taking him as a person
aside why does his message resonate with
the young men so much and it's not the
fact that he is some sort of superhero
character but because there's clearly a
gap with young men in talking about you
know actual positive forms of
masculinity he is he is a symptom not
the cause and we need to be talking
about that instead of making this a
cultural issue and saying actually it's
men being bad to women Jenny I can hear
your sigh from here during that what's
your response well I just I just I don't
see the two as mutually exclusive I
think you know it's all very well I
think it's totally right that parents
should be having this discussion with
their children but what if your dad is
Andrew Tate what if your dad has all of
these opinions we asked schools to to
have phhe lessons this could be part of
that it doesn't necessarily have to be
an extra amount of workload and it's a
sort of thing that can very easily be
included in a curriculum without making
boys feel like being a man is a bad
thing we're quite good at teaching
difficulties so you don't have a problem
with the way it's framed this is they
didn't say we're going to teach people
how to respect each other it says we are
going to teach boys how to respect girls
to crack down on Ladish culture but
there's such a thing as toxic femininity
women being horrible to young boys yeah
we don't talk about the flips but I
think the effects of toxic masculinity
of like men putting revenge porn videos
online which women don't tend to do can
ruin lives in a in a different way there
aren't the kind of women influences
encouraging young women to go and ruin
isn't that the point here which is that
actually this isn't necessarily a
conversation about how women are
negatively affecting young boys I mean
what this is proposing is to teach young
men that it's not right to video you
having sex with your girlfriend and then
post it on the internet you can get
arrested for that it's illegal to do
that you shouldn't do it and trying to
guide people in what is in some cases a
new world yes of social media but in
others just actually a behavior of your
code that has kind of grown up piece by
piece that some people actually do
struggle but then what about you know
young women filming men at the gym and
then claiming their business how many
times how many times have you seen that
they do that no that goes viral on Tick
Tock no but I'm saying I'm saying the
issue with labor is one I do think this
is a distraction because I don't think
people are thinking oh actually the cost
of my food is going up so let's teach
young boys how to speak to women in
schools I don't think that's their
priority I think it's a distraction but
I think the bigger issue here is they
are framing it as a cultural issue if
you don't want to make it look like the
owner is always on men and how men
behave in society
you have to phrase it differently I
think there are a lot of culturals but I
don't I think you're wrong this isn't
Being Framed as a culture no but I
framed a focused
let Jenny let's Jenny speak I think this
is Being Framed not in terms of cultural
Wars at all it's Being Framed in terms
of uh really low rates of prosecution
when it comes to rape conviction this is
the Justice this is not a cultural we
have a problem in this country and we
have to look at the core causes of those
kinds of crimes as well as looking at
Prosecuting them so but that's that's a
problem for the justice system not young
kids in school my issue is when you're
telling young impressionable you know
teenage boys and girls that actually the
issue is how boys are treating girls
you're friendly as a cultural issue
because there's no onus on women to
behave is there any problem with having
a conversation about this because it's
clear that sex education in schools is a
total mess there's a Government Review
going on about it now parents aren't
happy with finding out what's going why
not have a I won't have to talk about it
without framing families in homes where
people are actually being not everyone
has that but I'm sorry but that's not
the government's responsibility the
government barely gets many things right
why are we now offshoring more
responsibilities some things just to
parents and some children are going to
have absolutely no information at all
apart from Andrew Tate and other
people's parents if you leave all of
this solely to parents some parents are
not very good if you leave parents
parents are good at it
of the parents jobs that's the thing
that some of them can't do their job and
you've got to step into the voice I'm
sorry that's not the government's job
the government's barely getting policing
right our roads are full of
potholescence
for a lot of safeguarding for a lot of
parts so let's take a step back here
because what Jenny's saying is that you
know the rate of rape and sexual assault
prosecutions for example let's take
something that that fundamentally mostly
affects women in this country are really
low in some cases politicians including
from the labor party said that rape is
all but legal now because of your
chances of being prosecuted you seem to
be suggesting before that that has
nothing to do with culture has nothing
to do with behavior has nothing to do
with attitudes but actually in a lot of
cases rape is not strangers it's people
that we know it's a boyfriend it's a
person that you've met on a night out
that's about culture isn't it but I
don't think equating I mean there's a
huge gap between how men and women or
young young boys and girls interact with
each other there's a huge gap to get
from there to rape and you know the
level the level um the level which rape
is prosecuted in this country I think
the prosecution rate is about that 10 I
don't think it's a gap I think it's a
Continuum no it's not a Continuum I
don't I don't agree with that at all
because you cannot say that actually to
reduce the level of you know break
prosecutions in this country we need to
teach young boys how to use better
language how do you make that Gap when
it really should be the parents
responsibility is to treat to teach
their kids how to treat each other to
reduce the number of rapes you have to
increase the level of respect so that
people see the humanity of each other
and and don't treat each other rapists
just happen to forget that it's illegal
to rape is that no they don't see their
victims as fully
Humanity
they can it's got nothing to do with the
law it's to do with it
you're talking about yes I'm talking
about actually reducing the number of
rapes and the way to do that is to make
people respect each other and for men to
see women as as people
let's bring this back because it's a
labor policy and the labor party has
been a fair bit of criticism level to
secure St armor and you know the
leadership of his party about their
attitudes towards women let's just take
a quick look at this clip which is
secure stroma speaking
for the vast majority of women this is
all about biology and of course they
don't have a penis we all know that
99.9 something percent of women
um it's all biological and it's very
straightforward
I mean you both laughed there yes
99.9 almost their care
um look for the longest time Kirsten has
treated this whole trans issue as as
just a cultural thing I mean Rosie
Duffield has made it very clear that the
leader of her party really tried to
distance himself from it because he
thought it was just something that was
you know down to the culture war and he
didn't want to engage with it to breathe
life into something that he didn't think
was a big issue but clearly it is a big
issue because many women in this country
as unhappy as they may be with the toys
are generally envisaging a scenario
where the labor party will come into
government and you start to see you know
trans rights in in women's spaces go go
haywire and it really rolls back women's
uh rights in that way and so I I don't
think the the argument should be whether
you know
young boys should be taught how to speak
to girls to reduce prosecution rates
it's about the labor party actually
taking women's rights seriously and
stopping you know distracting from the
real issues by saying actually just
teach your kids in school better when
that's not really a domain they should
be involved it here Stormer would say
that he is taking women's rights uh
seriously because him and the trans the
the uh the gender critical women they
all agreed on the same thing which is
the problem that women face is violence
from men violence from male-bodied
people
yes from men from men people with
penises I'm happy I'm happy
I'm happy to call it like it is and I
think that's what Kia stormers is saying
today with this with this education the
greatest threat that women face is from
men how is that legitimate though
because he can't even he's staying 99.99
very uncomfortable because he realizes
those questions because he's
illegitimate but do you think this is
this is almost been as far as I can see
trying to run away from talking about
these issues that seem to get him in
trouble with those clips do you think
he's now trying to actually take that
fight to the to the government in the
culture wars and do you think it works
there I think it will certainly uh do a
lot better for him among feminists than
uh his inability to answer the question
of what a woman is I just think it's
completely disingenuous I mean the fact
that yesterday he couldn't Define what a
woman is now he's saying 99.9 of women
don't have penises which of course
leaves the question of what happened to
0.1 percent of women that apparently do
have a penis I mean how does he have any
credibility on this issue do you think
this is an election deciding issue do
you think voters really care about this
when they're going into the balance is
the next election no but I think they do
care about crime they do care about
crime and that's what he was trying to
bring it back to today by talking about
violence against women and girls and
education is part of that but yes this
is part of a wider remit of things he's
talking about which is to do with crime
I think the labor party really should be
focusing on the core issues I'm not
saying this is not a core issue but
the reality is most people's concerns
have to do with the cost of living
crisis security immigration all of that
I cannot believe that with with most
people facing these concerns the labor
party's Grand solution is actually let's
teach boys how to speak to girls in
schools I mean that's quite frankly not
a priority that's a parent's job not to
the government well I mean I think we've
covered
Jenny Esther thanks so much thank both
of you for joining us this evening
well next tonight Harry and Megan are
caught on celeb camp at a basketball
game in La was it a royally awkward
night for the notoriously private couple
we'll debate that after the break
thank you
[Music]
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel no what
are you every little helps for God's
sake is nothing original anymore it's
finger licking Goods I'm loving it look
let's be honest we don't have any fancy
speech writers here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7 p.m join me just do it
well that one too
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Feltz on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
coming up on the talk Keith starler
watch schoolboys have lessons on how to
treat women Megan rejects Prince Harry
when they're asked to pucker up for a
kiss cam and heco Vandal sprayed
graffiti on SUVs that's all at nine
o'clock
[Music]
welcome back Prince Harry and Meghan
Markle made a surprise the basketball
game in La last night the couple who now
live in California are all smiles over
the scene cheering on the Lakers with a
celebrity camera up on the big screen
but many Royal fans are questioned why
the notoriously private pair will be so
comfortable appearing on television well
we're joined Now by talk TV contributor
Paula Brown Adrian and talk TV presenter
Richard Tice lovely to have you both
with us but let's start with that clip
because Richard it is incredibly awkward
whatever you think about it I mean he
goes in for a kiss she completely Dodges
it what's going on there good question
I'm actually not their greatest fans and
I've been pretty critical in the past
but actually I thought the whole thing
the photos I thought it was rather sweet
I thought they were in great form uh
smiling having fun actually that's sort
of what what they should be doing in a
sense if they've done a lot more of that
we may not be in the place we're in
frankly having fun being celebrities you
know on the west coast that's that's who
they are that's what they are we almost
want to see more of it don't worry about
the odd kiss or Miss yeah followers is
part of of I mean maybe I'm too cynical
but do you think this is part of a bit
of a Rebrand trying to ensure that
people see them as you know as Richard
says as celebrities young people having
a good time and not just being really
critical of the royal family ahead of
the coronation of course which is just
in a couple of weeks time you're right
you are 40 typical
you know and it has to be said let's
take ourselves right back to the day
when Harry and Megan stood in Buckingham
Palace and gave the speech about you
know having to sadly leave
um and and move away this wasn't about
seeking privacy they wanted to be able
to continue to add value to the royal
family in terms of doing charitable work
and they've continued to do that this
isn't about seeking out publicity
they may have added to People's Bank
balances selling books and all sorts of
stories yes
they want privacy except when they don't
want privacy on their own terms and
they're very good at their own PR but
the second anyone else holds up a mirror
or perhaps asks an awkward question the
shutters come down absolutely not and
this is an absolute classic example and
can I just say why haven't they done
more of that can I just say in terms of
that footage did anyone hear any booing
did anyone no no I didn't think so
perhaps if the Duchess of Sussex came to
London for the coronation this was well
there would be some booing there they
would be welcomed and anybody who did
boo them I think would probably be
castigated because that's just not what
the Great British public do in terms of
celebrating and supporting the royal
family Richard on that point do you
think people have moved on now I mean if
if Megan did come over for the
coronation which we know that she's not
going to I mean chances are she probably
wouldn't be booed would she I don't
think actually they would be booed for
the reasons you've just inferred the
British people are recognizing the
respect the pomp the ceremony but
actually I nevertheless I think risk
reduction they've made the right call
and Harry's going to pop over and then
disappear pretty quickly and frankly go
and have fun like that and that's if
they're carried on doing more of that
than that would have been adding value
but I'm afraid that's not I was going to
say I could I could hear Piers Morgan
screaming at the television thank you
Harry called brought it back around I'm
sure he was very pleased with that it's
very good here
Paula Richard was just talking now about
the Great British public and their
respect for institutions but I want to
show you a little clip because just stop
oil you know huge protests they've been
sitting in the road they've been walking
slowly through the Streets of London
just have a look at this guy who had
absolutely no time for those protesters
move that away
[Music]
come on mate come on come on Richard is
that the is that the backbone of Britain
is that the best public there he is
absolutely right I thought you might say
that he's doing the job that the British
Bobby should be doing
the 1980s highways act I know I'm you
know I've actually read the stuff it
says they cannot willfully obstruct the
highway and the police should be moving
him off the highway protest peacefully
lawfully on the pavement wonderful we
can enjoy your lovely banners but don't
block the highway and if the police
won't do the job they're supposed to do
then the Great British public end up
having to do it yeah well Richard you
would also know that of course you have
the right to protest yes and that is
what these people were doing and what
they were doing was trying to save our
lives Richard we know they're
endangering lives on the highway the
statistics have told us that in 10 years
time
please Millions annually in terms of
death due to Drought we know we know
that in 20 years time we are being told
about about famine and what that is
going to happen in terms of the movement
of people and let's be honest if
anyone's worried about the 46 000 that
made it across the channel we are going
to see far higher numbers due to what
due to climate change and fine so if you
get to Net Zero tomorrow the ipcc report
says how long will it take until sea
level rise stops is it one year is it
two years is it five years what's the
answer well shall I tell you what I'll
tell you what the answer is
I'll tell you what Professor King told
us who of course was the advisor for the
government he told us we had three to
four years didn't it you'll be aware
without getting into the Net Zero debate
too much we've had many many times
before just on that quickly where does
the where do you both think the right of
one person's right to protest infringes
on another person's right to go about
their business and earn their class go
to work and get to work there's a clash
there and this is the fundamental issue
with Justin boilers there isn't there is
a clash there but should I tell you what
worries me the most is that whilst our
prime minister is surrounded by his
six-yard police protecting him from
these people from they didn't know they
didn't attack
they didn't attack him they were fully
protesting and that's what just oil do
say they are peaceful no they're not
they're obstructing it so whilst Richie
sunac was was being you know cocooned by
the by the police what we have is a
member of the public frustrated
frustrated attacking the protesters it's
that frustration that I'm afraid our
government have let no so so you
actually support me your base is saying
the police are not doing the job
Harry's just referred to and they
consistently fail to uphold the law
that's what I'd like them disciplined
for failing to uphold them so Richard
what's the answer here because these
guys are not going to stop protesting in
fact the coronation is a prime
opportunity for them to protest the
front page of some of the newspapers of
the weekend carrying pretty worrying
stories about things like rape alarms
being thrown at horses to distract them
on the parade and if they do that they
will continue to damage their reputation
come from but if they do that I suspect
their PR people would say that's a
catastrophic mistake because the Great
British people we want a fantastic
wonderful coronation of Pomp and
ceremony that goes off faultlessly yeah
we don't want these grungy people
interfering it they've had their
protests but you protest lawfully people
there's nothing wrong with being granted
I saw them yesterday with their little
their little diesel-powered uh glory and
there were a bunch of about 20 or 30
grungy people frankly most of them
because they need to go have a bath on
them well let's let's move on because we
haven't got much time left I want to
bring you both back to politics because
this is our favorite subject and talk
about the SMP because Nicholas sturgeon
has been speaking today she's obviously
had a difficult time of it her party is
in an even more difficult position Paula
let's just have a quick listen to what
she said today
I understand
the The View that some people might have
that I knew this was all about to unfold
and that's why I walked away I'm not
thinking before the truth I could not
have anticipated in my worst nightmares
I thought would have unfolded over the
past few weeks I believe the SNP
notwithstanding the the real
difficulties that surrounds at the party
just now is in good shape
now follow there are two things about
that clip the first is that people are
saying it shows Nicola sturgeon so
showing some genuine emotion but the
second is I mean she's saying no it's a
real it's a nightmare it's a stuffer
nightmares I mean her party and and the
new SMP leader has been left to pick up
the pieces here well I mean she she
she's still a Scottish Member of
Parliament isn't it so you know she's
still going to be having to deal with
this you know and and in terms of what
her voters are saying to her this must
be incredibly hard so in terms of as an
individual in terms of what's happening
with you know her husband in terms of
what's happening with the party this is
absolutely massive I have to say the
suggestion that you know this is the
first time we're seeing her show in
motion we saw her show in real emotion
when she um resigned well some people
said that that it wasn't real emotion
because she knew exactly what was about
to happen and it was very welcome I
think it was Terror it could have been
complete terrorists but it was
extraordinary In that clip one moment
she said it's a nightmare nightmare and
the next moment she says the SMP is in
good shape she must be the only person
in the whole of the United Kingdom that
thinks the SMP what can she say I mean
this might have been one of those rare
moments where I should have been best
saying not a lot because I mean polls
don't seem to be really shifting in
Scotland the s p remain very popular and
so the real question is given that there
are two Independence parties the extent
to which if people lose confidence in
the SMP I think a true independent
supporter is much more likely to go to
Alex Salmon's Albert he's he's the guy
with the great opportunity why would you
then go to labor that doesn't doesn't
seem logical to me
I just think in terms of who the snpr
and what they s p are and who they mean
to Scottish people I don't think that
they are concerned as you're suggesting
that they should be I do think that they
have a very strong base and that that
strong base will continue did you
believe the crocodile tears though
I'm literally drowning underneath those
were real tears just like the real love
we saw for Harry and Megan right look
we've only got a minute average and I
want to get your thoughts on this uh
briefly in a word both of you I'm going
to ask you President Biden he's
announced today he's going to stand
again is he too old for office he is but
he had no choice otherwise he would have
had a lame duck presidency presidency
for the last 18 20 months he had to say
that but I don't think that he will be
uh actually on the ballot paper in
November 2024.
oh wow
I have to be honest with you I'm
disappointed
um it's a shame that you didn't feel it
appropriate to Mentor someone Paula
Richard on that note thank you so much
for your thoughts thank you for joining
us this evening and thank you for
watching because that is it from us
Piers Morgan we hope you feel much
better tomorrow what you're up to
whatever you're up to all of you make
sure it is uncensored good night
[Music]
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel no we're
gonna use uh every little helps for
God's sake is nothing original anymore
it's finger licking Goods I'm loving it
look let's be honest we don't have any
fancy speech writers here but we do and
I promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it what
that one too
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Feltz on talk to